[Music]
i don't think any other stock has
captivated investors on wall street or
main street the way tesla has it's just
become
one of the most controversial names and
one of the most
watched names out there this summer
tesla became the most valuable auto
company in the world
surpassing toyota and claiming a market
cap of over 190 billion dollars before
continuing its climb
the electric vehicle maker stocks
speeding this year must wealth
skyrocketing thanks to a surge in tesla
shares
making him wealthier than warren buffett
but the company's fundamentals don't
seem to explain the rise
for example toyota sold almost 25 times
as many vehicles as tesla did last year
instead the rally has been driven by
investor enthusiasm for ceo
elon musk in a belief by some that in
the future
cars everywhere will be powered by
batteries not gasoline
here's how tesla became the most
valuable automaker
in the world tesla developed its first
car in the early 2000s
but to follow its ballooning share price
a good place to start is last fall
in october 2019 tesla reported a
surprise profit for its latest quarter
and that just sent its
shares soaring just a few months prior
tesla shares were hovering near a
three-year low
the prior year elon musk had tweeted
that he was going to take
tesla private at 420 a share and that
landed him in the crosshairs
of regulators he'd also kind of had a
history of missing financial targets and
car delivery targets
so that's why this surprise earnings
beat was a really big deal
amid the rush of investor optimism in
mid-november
musk held an event in los angeles to
reveal tesla's
cyber truck what he did was he unveiled
this pickup truck that looked unlike
any other pickup truck we had ever seen
before and he boasted that
it was really really durable at the
event
a tesla employee threw a metal ball at
the window to show its strength
but ended up breaking the glass oh i
should say also we're gonna be offering
rides in this all night
[Applause]
don't mind the glass the next day
shares fell more than six percent but
amid press around the event
the stock quickly recovered and on
december 23rd
it surged past 420
the reason that 420 mark is kind of a
milestone is that
you know that was kind of the tweet that
landed musk in the crosshairs of
regulators
the sec later said the tweet was a
reference to marijuana culture that musk
used to amuse his girlfriend
the shares crossing 420 later in the
year it was kind of a victory in that
sense
in the following weeks tesla had a
string of wins the company said it met
its delivery goal
of 360 000 cars for the year and
less than a year after breaking ground
at its china plant the car maker met its
objective for model 3 production at the
facility
and held a press conference to celebrate
deliveries of china made
model 3s to chinese customers many
people
view china as the world's biggest market
for electric vehicles so in order for
tesla to kind of
make this journey from you know just a
small startup to
a global behemoth producing electric
cars
bullish investors say that it needs to
target that market
so this boosted expectations for the
coming year
the investor momentum continued when on
january 29th
tesla posted a profit for the second
quarter in a row
on the earnings call the company said it
was well on its way to producing its
next car
the model y compact sport utility
vehicle and it told investors the
business should be profitable going
forward
so this was around the time that tesla
shares
really just started to go parabolic and
you saw
wall street investors main street
investors kind of all piling
into tesla shares tesla options and it
just kind of became this huge
frenzy around the company but not
everyone was betting for the car company
the fascinating thing about tesla is
that despite its kind of meteoric
rise in the stock market this year it
remains one of the most popular
shorts so that means it's a really
popular bet for investors who think that
the shares are going to absolutely
plummet when the stock goes up that's
painful for a short investor that means
that they're losing money
so some people can't hold on to these
money losing positions for too long so
they have to close out their position
and sometimes they do that by buying
tesla stock
and this kind of unusual twist you have
investors who
think the shares are going to go down
actually helping
to drive it up but this stock run-up was
stopped short in march
despite investor enthusiasm tesla was
not immune to the market effects of the
coronavirus lockdowns
that month california issued stay at
home orders
leading tesla to suspend production at a
factory and interrupting the company's
ramp up for its newest vehicle
the stock fell in march and then quickly
bounced back as the market started to
recover
at the heart of this downturn the
federal reserve enacted a massive
stimulus plan to buoy the economy
fueling a broader recovery in the stock
market that also lifted stocks like
tesla on april 29th
tesla reported another profit the third
in a row
even through the low of the s p 500 the
s p
was down roughly 30 percent year to date
and meanwhile
even through that time frame tesla stock
was up so despite
a recession a global pandemic that could
crimp demand for cars
tesla stock has has still been resilient
this year
then on june 10th investors pushed the
automaker's stock past a thousand
dollars a share for the first time ever
after musk told employees it was time to
begin production on the company's
all-electric semi-trailer truck
by july tesla became the world's most
valuable car maker overtaking toyota
and on the second musk taunted the short
sellers when shares opened above 1
200 for the first time after tesla
deliveries beat expectations
and investors anticipated the company's
inclusion in the s p
500 index in order to be considered for
the s p 500 a company needs to deliver
a cumulative profit over four
consecutive quarters
including the most recent so even before
tesla's
most recent earnings report a ton of
investors were anticipating
hey we think it's going to be profitable
this quarter we think it's going to be
in the s p 500 and that
drove the stock even higher on an
earnings call on july 22nd
tesla said it hit that goal defying the
wall street bears who expected a loss
we were able to achieve a fourth
consecutive profitable quarter
and although the automotive industry was
down about 30 percent year-over-year in
the first half a year
we managed to grow deliveries in the
first half of the year
if you bought 10 shares of tesla last
june in june 2019
it would have cost you a little more
than 1700
if you held on to that investment
through late july
it would have been worth more than
fifteen thousand dollars
bears still say the stock is going to go
down they don't think that tesla will
bring
electric vehicles to the masses